Mais cette présentation est vraiment centrée sur les sciences et l'ingénierie
et ce qui m'a le plus étonné dans cette expérience,
c'est que Taber ait dit : « Oui, je crois que nous pouvons fabriquer
une combinaison et, plus encore,
passe demain et voyons comment mettre sur pied une équipe »,
équipe que nous avons ensuite constituée.
Et ils ont fait quelque chose qui, je crois, est important :
ils ont fait une analogie avec la plongée sous-marine.
Donc en plongée,
vous avez un système autonome.
Vous avez tout ce dont vous pourriez avoir besoin.
Vous avez des bouteilles de plongée.
Vous portez une combinaison de plongée.
Il vous faut de la visibilité.
Et la plongée, c'est exactement ce système,
et nous allons le lancer dans la stratosphère.
Et trois ans plus tard, voici le résultat.
Nous avons cette superbe combinaison fabriquée par ILC Dover.
C'est eux qui ont fabriqué les combinaisons du programme Apollo,
et toutes les combinaisons pour les activités extra-véhiculaires.
Ils n'avaient jamais vendu une combinaison à un particulier,
juste au gouvernement,
mais ils m'en ont vendu une, et je leur en suis très reconnaissant.
Ici, c'est un parachute. Tout était question de sécurité.
Tous les membres de l'équipe savaient
que j'ai une femme et deux enfants,
10 et 15 ans,
et que je voulais revenir sans encombres.
Ainsi, il y a un parachute principal et un parachute de secours,
et sans action de ma part,
le parachute de secours se serait déclenché de façon automatique.
La combinaison peut me protéger du froid.
Cette zone-là, devant, est une protection thermique.
Elle réchauffe l'eau qui s'écoule autour de mon corps.
Elle possède deux réservoirs d'oxygène redondants.
Même si ma combinaison se perçait,
ce qui est peu probable,
ce système m'aurait protégé de la faible pression dans l'espace.
Le principal avantage de ce système, c'est son poids et sa simplicité.
Le système pèse 230 kg environ,
à comparer à d'autres tentatives récentes pour aller là-haut,
en utilisant une capsule.
Pour utiliser une capsule, sans parler de l'incroyable complexité qui va avec,
vous devez soulever environ 1350 kg ;
et pour soulever 1350 kg et atteindre l'altitude de 40 km,
qui était mon objectif,
il m’aurait fallu un ballon entre 1 et 1,5 millions de m3.
C'est parce que l'ensemble pesait 230 kg seulement
que nous avons pu utiliser un ballon 5 fois plus petit pour cette opération,
et cela nous a permis d'utiliser un système de lancement bien plus simple
que celui dont nous aurions eu besoin pour un ballon beaucoup plus grand.
Sachant cela, je vous emmène à Roswell, au Nouveau-Mexique, ce 24 Octobre.
Notre fantastique équipe s'est réveillée au milieu de la nuit.
Voici la combinaison.
Ici, le chargeur frontal que vous allez voir dans un instant,
et je veux vous montrer une vidéo du véritable lancement.
Roswell est un endroit superbe pour lancer des ballons,
mais c'est aussi un endroit magnifique pour se poser en parachute,
surtout quand vous vous posez à plus de 100 km du départ.
Il y a un camion d'hélium à l'arrière-plan.
C'est la nuit.
J'ai déjà passé près d'une heure et demie de pré-respiration.
Ici, l'installation de l'équipement.
Cela prend environ une heure pour le revêtir.
Les astronautes ont ces super mini-bus climatisés
pour aller sur le pas de tir, mais moi j'ai un chargeur frontal !
(Rires)
Vous pouvez voir le ballon là-haut.
C'est là que se trouve l'hélium.
Là, c'est Dave qui demande à l'aviation civile de vider l'espace aérien.
Et c'est parti.
(Rires)
C'est moi, agitant ma main gauche.
La raison pour laquelle j'agite ma main gauche
est que ma main droite actionne l'arrêt d'urgence.
(Rires)
Mon équipe m'a interdit d'utiliser ma main droite.
Donc, le voyage est beau. C'est un peu comme Google Earth en sens inverse.
(Rires)
Il a fallu deux heures et sept minutes pour monter,
et elles ont été des plus paisibles.
Mon rythme cardiaque était très bas,
et je tentais de ne pas utiliser beaucoup d'oxygène.
Vous pouvez observer que les champs en arrière-plan
sont encore assez grands à ce stade,
et vous pouvez me voir monter et monter.
Là, c'est intéressant, si vous regardez,
je suis juste au-dessus de l'aéroport, à 15 000 m,
mais juste après, je suis poussé par un vent stratosphérique
de près de 200 km/h.
Ici, mon directeur de vol m'indique que je viens de voler
plus haut que n'importe qui d'autre en ballon,
et j'étais à 1200 m de la libération.
Voilà à quoi ça ressemble.
Vous pouvez voir l'obscurité de l'espace, la courbure de la Terre,
la fragile planète en dessous.
A ce moment, je pratique mentalement mes procédures d'urgence.
Si quelque chose tourne mal, je veux être prêt.
Le plus important que j'ai à faire ici
est de déclencher la libération et chuter de façon stable.
(Vidéo) Contrôle au sol : « Tout le monde est prêt ?
5...4...3...2..1. »
Alan Eustace : C'est le ballon qui file, entièrement gonflé à ce point.
Et là, vous pouvez voir un parachute stabilisateur,
je vais vous en montrer un, parce que c'est vraiment important.
Encore le ballon qui passe.
A ce moment, je chute à la vitesse du son.
je ne m'en aperçois pas, c'est la vitesse du son,
et très bientôt, je vais effectivement aller plus vite que jamais,
1322 km/h.
(Vidéo) Contrôle au sol : « Nous perdons les données. »
AE : Là, je suis beaucoup plus bas
et vous pouvez en principe voir le parachute sortir ici.
À cet instant, je suis très heureux qu'il y ait un parachute.
Je croyais être le seul,
mais il s'avère que toute l'équipe était heureuse également.
La chose vraiment cool est qu'au moment précis où je l'ouvrais,
un de mes amis très proche, Blikkies, mon partenaire de vol,
s'est élancé d'un avion
et a atterri à mes côtés.
Il était mon ailier au cours de la descente.
Ceci est mon atterrissage, mais je devrais plutôt dire mon crash !
(Rires)
Et je dois bien l'admettre, j'ai fait des atterrissages bien pires que ça !
(Applaudissements)
(Vidéo) « Comment ça va? »
AE: « Salut à tous ! »
Ouais.
(Rires)
Je tiens donc à vous dire une chose
que vous pourriez ne pas avoir vue dans cette vidéo,
mais un des moment les plus critiques de toute l'opération a été la libération
et ce qui ce passe juste après.
Nous avons essayé d'utiliser une chose appelée un parachute stabilisateur,
il était donc là pour me stabiliser.
Et je vais vous en montrer un tout de suite.
Si l'un d'entre vous a déjà fait du parachutisme en tandem,
il en a probablement utilisé un.
Mais le problème avec ce machin,
c'est que dès la libération vous êtes en apesanteur.
Il est donc très facile pour cette chose de vous entourer.
Et avant de vous en rendre compte, vous êtes empêtré, ou tournez comme une toupie
ou vous déclenchez le stabilisateur trop tard
et dans ce cas, puisque vous chutez à plus de 1000 km/h,
il se disloque
et devient inutile.
Mais les gars de United Parachute Technologies ont trouvé cette idée,
c'était un rouleau qui ressemble à ça,
mais regardez ce qui arrive quand je le sors.
Il forme un tube.
Ce tube est si solide
que vous pouvez prendre ce parachute le faire tournoyer autour,
il n'a aucun moyen de s'emmêler à vous.
Et cela a éliminé un problème potentiel très grave.
Donc rien n'est possible sans une équipe de gens formidables.
Le noyau de cette équipe était d'environ 20 personnes
qui ont travaillé pendant trois ans,
et ils ont été incroyables.
On me demande quelle a été la meilleure partie de toute cette affaire
et je réponds la chance de travailler avec les meilleurs experts
en météorologie, en ballon ascensionnel, en technologie des parachutes,
dans les systèmes environnementaux, en médecine de haute altitude.
C'était magique. C'est un rêve d'ingénieur de travailler avec un tel groupe.
Et, dans le même temps, je tiens à remercier mes amis chez Google,
à la fois pour leur soutien dans cet effort,
et en me remplaçant quand j'étais absent.
Mais il y a un autre groupe que je tiens à remercier, et c'est ma famille.
Ouais.
(Applaudissements)
Je voulais constamment les rassurer à propos de la sécurité de la technologie,
mais ils n'écoutaient pas.
C'était très dur pour eux,
et la seule raison pour laquelle ma femme a toléré tout ça,
c'est parce que je suis revenu avec la banane après chacun des 250 tests,
et elle ne voulait pas m'enlever ça.
Je veux conclure par une anecdote.
Ma fille Katelyn, elle a 15 ans, elle et moi étions dans la voiture,
et nous roulions, et elle était assise là,
et la voilà qui part : « Papa, j'ai une super idée. »
Alors je l'écoute et je lui réponds : « Katelyn, c'est impossible. »
Alors elle me regarde et déclare :
« Papa, après ce que tu viens de faire,
comment peux-tu encore dire que quelque chose est impossible ? »
Alors j'ai souri et j'ai répondu : « Bon ce n'est pas impossible,
c'est juste très très difficile. »
Et puis après une courte pause, j'ai dit : « Katelyn,
ce n'est peut-être pas impossible, peut-être que ce n'est même pas très dur,
c'est juste que je ne sais pas comment le faire. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)